Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Kim Mills. Speaking of psychology is a podcast for anyone with an interest in the science of psychology. We talk to psychological researchers, practitioners, and educators about any and every aspect of psychology and its application to the world around us. Dr. Alex Pentland, also known as Sandy, is a professor of media arts and sciences at MIT, where he directs the MIT Connection Science and Human Dynamics Labs. He is one of the most cited scientists in the world, and Forbes magazine recently named him one of the seven most powerful data scientists in the world.
您好，欢迎收听由美国心理学会制作的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人金·米尔斯。《心理学谈话》是为所有对心理学科学感兴趣的人准备的播客。我们与心理学研究人员、从业者和教育工作者探讨心理学的方方面面及其在现实世界中的应用。亚历克斯·彭特兰博士（也被称为桑迪）是麻省理工学院媒体艺术与科学教授，他在那里指导麻省理工学院连接科学与人类动力学实验室。他是世界上被引用次数最多的科学家之一，《福布斯》杂志最近将他评为全球七位最有影响力的数据科学家之一。
Dr. Pentland's research focuses on social physics, big data, and privacy. His research helps people better understand the physics, of their social environment and helps individual companies and communities and people to reinvent themselves to be safer, more productive, and more creative. Thank you for speaking with APA today. My pleasure. So let's start with a definition. Social physics, what do you mean by that?
彭特兰博士的研究重点是社会物理学、大数据和隐私。他的研究帮助人们更好地理解其社会环境的物理特性，并帮助个人、公司、社区和人们重塑自我，从而变得更安全、更高效、更具创造力。感谢您今天接受美国心理学会的采访。不客气。那么，让我们从定义开始。社会物理学，您指的是什么？
Well, social physics is a word or phrase that's two centuries old. In the beginning of the 1800s, alchemy turned into chemistry and an attempt to clean up its act and natural science turned into physics. And there was this dream of doing something similar with understanding culture. And in France in particular, there was the idea of using data and statistics to really understand the progression of culture. And that spread to England very early on. And it's why we have the modern census, which asks all sorts of questions.
嗯，社会物理学是一个有两个世纪历史的词或短语。在19世纪初，炼金术变成了化学，并试图规范其行为，自然科学变成了物理学。当时人们梦想着在理解文化方面做类似的事情。特别是在法国，人们有了利用数据和统计数据来真正理解文化进程的想法。这种想法很早就传到了英国。这就是我们拥有现代人口普查的原因，它会询问各种各样的问题。
But until just recently, it's been very difficult to do. do very much because it's been very expensive to get data. You had to have surveys and so forth. And statistics were really not that powerful. In the last decade or so, though, you've seen this sort of floodgate of data coming available from cell phones and credit cards and government and everything's digital. And then very powerful machine learning methods that let you do statistics that were sort of unimaginable before. And that's social physics. It's the coming together of this new technologies to better understand ourselves. So one of the things that I think you have looked into
但直到最近，要做到这一点还非常困难，因为获取数据的成本非常高。你必须进行调查等等。而且统计数据确实没有那么强大。然而，在过去十年左右的时间里，你已经看到了来自手机、信用卡、政府和所有数字化事物的海量数据涌入。然后是极其强大的机器学习方法，让你能够进行以前无法想象的统计分析。这就是社会物理学。它是这些新技术汇聚在一起，以更好地了解我们自己。所以，我想您研究过的一件事是
is electronic interaction among people and what that does for creativity. Can you talk about what you've found in that area? Well, we've looked at many different sort of situations, you know, in schools and companies, just sort of out in the wild, as it were. And we do something unusual, which is we measure physical,
人与人之间的电子互动以及它对创造力的影响。您能谈谈您在这一领域发现了什么吗？嗯，我们观察了许多不同类型的情况，你知道，在学校和公司里，就像在野外一样。我们做了一件不寻常的事情，那就是我们测量物理
interaction along with the electronic interaction. So we actually build little name badges that keep account of, you know, who talked to who, where, things like that. And sometimes we ask people to put a little software on their phone so that we can keep track of, you know, who actually talked to each other on the telephone or who was nearby each other. And the sort of first thing to notice is that the electronic stuff is not as powerful as the face-to-face stuff. If you're talking about patterns that are predictive of life outcomes, of happiness, of social health. It's the face-to-say stuff that just beats it hand down.
互动以及电子互动。所以我们实际上制作了小名牌，记录谁和谁谈话，在哪里谈话，诸如此类的事情。有时我们要求人们在手机上安装一个小软件，这样我们就可以跟踪谁在电话里真正交谈过，或者谁在彼此附近。首先要注意的是，电子互动不如面对面互动强大。如果你谈论的是预测生活结果、幸福感、社会健康的模式，那么面对面的互动绝对胜出。
That's not to say it's not important. It can sort of bias things in various ways and get people hopped up in various things. But it's the face-to-face that reinforces and makes it catch. A way to think about that is that you can have a rumor on the Internet, but it's when you check it out with your neighbors and they go, yeah, I heard that too. that it really begins to sort of dig into your mind and you begin to take it seriously. Are you finding that because of all of this electronic communication capability that we have today, that there's less face-to-face interaction?
这并不是说它不重要。它可以在各种方面产生偏见，并让人们对各种事情感到兴奋。但正是面对面交流强化了它并使其产生影响。考虑这一点的一种方法是，你可以在互联网上听到谣言，但只有当你和邻居核实，他们说“是的，我也听说了”时，它才真正开始深入你的脑海，你才开始认真对待它。您是否发现，由于我们今天拥有的所有这些电子通信能力，面对面的互动减少了？
Well, it's certainly true among younger people. You know, I have kids and they spend an important time in their bedrooms, you know, doing various sort of stuff. And then there's a whole sort of culture of keeping kids really. really, really safe. So there's the free-range kids movement in reaction to that. Whereas when you and I were young, we sort of went out and did all sorts of stuff and maybe for good and maybe for bad. Good thing our parents don't know what we were doing. Yeah, well, I'm sure they didn't. But it's not actually clear which is right.
嗯，在年轻人中确实如此。你知道，我有孩子，他们花大量时间在卧室里，做各种各样的事情。而且还有一种让孩子保持非常、非常、非常安全的文化。因此，为了应对这种情况，出现了“散养孩子”运动。而当你我年轻的时候，我们出去做各种各样的事情，也许是好事，也许是坏事。幸好我们的父母不知道我们在做什么。是的，嗯，我相信他们确实不知道。但目前还不清楚哪种方式是正确的。
Certainly there are things that we did in our generation that weren't good for us or for society. we got ourselves in trouble various ways. And you can, and my kids, kids at this age, don't experience that. Of course, they substitute these online things, which are of questionable quality, and it tends to be a lot more vicious, actually, in various ways, because it has this sense of anonymity. So that's a trade-off. On the other hand, I think teenage pregnancies have gone down.
当然，我们这一代人做过一些对我们或社会不利的事情，我们以各种方式给自己惹了麻烦。而我的孩子们，这个年龄的孩子，并没有经历过这些。当然，他们用这些质量可疑的在线事物来代替，而且实际上在各种方面往往更恶毒，因为它有一种匿名感。所以这是一个权衡。另一方面，我认为青少年怀孕率下降了。
So there is an upside here. Yeah, okay. So, you know, the thing I have to worry about, or the thing I worry about is something I was to joke with my wife is that she'd want the kids to be clean and everything to be clean. And I said, no, no, let them eat dirt. Because it's when you have these negative experiences in a sort of controlled way that you build robustness and the ability to deal with these things. And so I worry that what they call snowflakeness, right, comes from the lack of experience in uncomfortable situations. They're not able to deal with it as well as you could, and you can fall apart. And that means that when you get out in the real world as an adult, you're going to have some trauma that you might have toughened yourself up when you were a kid.
所以这里有一个积极的一面。是的，好吧。所以，你知道，我必须担心的事情，或者我担心的事情是我常和妻子开玩笑说，她希望孩子们干净，一切都干净。我说，不，不，让他们吃点土。因为当你以一种受控的方式经历这些负面体验时，你才能建立韧性和处理这些事情的能力。所以我担心他们所说的“雪花心态”，正是源于在不舒服的情况下缺乏经验。他们无法像你那样处理它，你可能会崩溃。这意味着当你成年后进入现实世界时，你会遭受一些创伤，而如果你小时候能让自己坚强起来，本可以避免这些。
It's a trade-off. So you spoke earlier about the availability of vast amounts of data right now. What kinds of data sets are there out there that we haven't really looked at yet? What can we do with them? Well, everybody focuses on Twitter and Facebook and things like that. But those are your public expression. They're not what you really do. And in fact, what you express in the face,
这是一个权衡。所以你之前谈到了现在海量数据的可用性。目前有哪些我们还没有真正研究过的数据集？我们可以用它们做什么？嗯，每个人都关注推特、脸书之类的事情。但那些是你的公开表达。它们不是你真正做的事情。事实上，你在脸上
put on is often only distantly related to what you actually feel and what you actually do. The sort of data sets that are also out there increasingly are things like location from your cell phone. Where are you spending time? Who else is around? Or what do you buy from your credit card? Or what sort of public transportation do you have you from Uber or things like that?
表现出来的东西往往与你真实的感受和实际所做的事情相去甚远。越来越多的数据集还包括来自手机的位置信息。你把时间花在哪里？周围还有谁？或者你用信用卡买了什么？或者你从优步或其他类似平台获得了什么样的公共交通服务？
And then there's all the government data about you. Everything's digital these days. The result is you can get a very, very detailed picture of somebody's actual behavior. Not what they say, not their public phase, but what they actually do in a way that was just inconceivable a decade ago. Most of that data is legally protected. It's siloed away fairly safely, actually. You don't hear a lot about it.
还有所有关于你的政府数据。如今一切都是数字化的。结果是，你可以非常、非常详细地了解某人的实际行为。不是他们说什么，不是他们的公开面孔，而是他们实际上做了什么，这在十年前是不可想象的。大部分数据在法律上受到保护。实际上，它们被相当安全地隔离了。你不会听到太多关于它们的消息。
But inevitably it will begin to come together in various ways. one of the ways that's important is in research. We don't really have this sort of picture of human existence of day-to-day life, of our social health, of our communities that we'd like to have. Most of our data comes from little laboratory experiments or questionnaires, and it's actually very biased, very limited, very expensive. And so you can imagine that you could make some of this data available in an anonymous, you know, contractually controlled sort of way,
但不可避免地，它们将开始以各种方式汇聚在一起。其中一个重要方面是研究。我们并没有真正拥有我们想要的关于人类生存、日常生活、社会健康、社区的这种图景。我们的大部分数据来自小型实验室实验或问卷调查，实际上非常片面、非常有限、非常昂贵。所以你可以想象，你可以以一种匿名、合同控制的方式提供其中一些数据，
where you can make meters, you know, sort of happiness of risk of stress for communities pretty much in real time. And in fact, the experiments we've done show that that's not only possible, but it's practical, enough so that in the last couple of years, I and some of my compatriots were able to convince the United Nations to put into the sustainable development,
你可以几乎实时地为社区的幸福感、风险、压力等建立指标。事实上，我们所做的实验表明，这不仅是可能的，而且是实用的，以至于在过去几年里，我和我的一些同仁能够说服联合国将可持续发展目标纳入其中，
goals, their 15-year goals, the notion of actually measuring things like happiness and inequality and sustainability using all of those sort of data sources. Nobody knows quite what they're going to have to do to do that because most of those data are held by companies. But there's ideas like making a data tax. Why doesn't the telephone company report sort of aggregate statistics to the government where everybody can see it, that would let us see, is this neighborhood a ghetto,
他们的15年目标，即利用所有这些数据源来实际衡量幸福感、不平等和可持续性等指标。没有人确切知道他们将不得不做什么来做到这一点，因为这些数据大多由公司持有。但有一些想法，比如征收数据税。为什么电话公司不向政府报告汇总统计数据，让每个人都能看到呢？这将使我们能够看到，这个社区是贫民窟，
or is this neighborhood nicely integrated with the rest of society? Turns out integration of a community with society is enormously predictive of outcomes, of whether the kids grow up happy or grow up at all. But how could you tell that from phone records? Don't we have other data that tell us those things? Other than phone records, mobility data, like you might get from transportation,
还是这个社区与社会其他部分融合得很好？事实证明，社区与社会的融合对结果有巨大的预测作用，无论是孩子们是否快乐成长，还是他们是否能长大成人。但你怎么能从电话记录中看出这一点呢？我们没有其他数据告诉我们这些吗？除了电话记录，还有移动数据，比如你可能从交通部门获得的数据，
or if everybody's using credit cards, if you're in a place where that's true, those are the sources of what people actually do, whether they actually spend time with other people or whether they talk to each other within the community. You can go do surveys all you want. What you're going to get is, oh, yes, we talk to everybody. Sure, sure.
或者如果每个人都在使用信用卡，如果你身处一个确实如此的地方，这些就是人们实际行为的来源，他们是否真的花时间与其他人在一起，或者他们是否在社区内交谈。你可以随心所欲地进行调查。你会得到的是，“哦，是的，我们和每个人都交谈。”当然，当然。
There's essentially no information at all. But when you look at things like, well, what's the pattern? of calls within the neighborhood and outside of the neighborhood. Not anybody, not any individual, just a neighborhood. You can predict things like crime rate very accurately. You can predict GDP very accurately. You can predict life expectancy.
本质上根本没有信息。但当你观察诸如“社区内外的通话模式”之类的事情时。不是任何人，不是任何个人，只是一个社区。你可以非常准确地预测犯罪率。你可以非常准确地预测GDP。你可以预测预期寿命。
You can even predict infant mortality with great accuracy by the sort of social connectedness of the community. So our government has a lot of data about us that they are not doing anything with? Yeah, that's, just recently there's been a lot of hoo-ha about Facebook and all that. Okay, yeah, that's all valid. But the other side of the coin is
你甚至可以通过社区的社会联系程度非常准确地预测婴儿死亡率。所以我们的政府有很多关于我们的数据，但他们什么都没做？是的，那是，最近关于脸书等等有很多喧嚣。好吧，是的，那都是有效的。但硬币的另一面是
the government has an enormous amount of data about it that's not being used to understand where there are problems. So an example would be sort of the broken windows policy of, you know, 15 years ago, I guess now. There was a sort of initial assessment of that looked good, so people implemented it everywhere in the country. Now, the government had lots of data that could have shown that it wasn't working the way people thought. But nobody thought to look. They didn't want to release it.
政府拥有大量关于它的数据，但没有被用来了解问题所在。例如，15年前的“破窗政策”。当时有一个初步评估看起来不错，所以人们在全国各地实施了它。现在，政府拥有大量数据，本可以显示它并没有像人们想象的那样运作。但没有人想到去查看。他们不想发布它。
It wasn't their job, something. And the result is, is we got a decade of broken windows policy where we never looked at whether it was working. And that you can see today, there's a lot of distress about that. you know, people are mad. And the question to me is, is why doesn't the government make data that it has available for research, you know, in a controlled way and safe, so there's no questions about privacy, but in a way that allows public debate and scientific evaluation of whether the government and its policies are working?
这不是他们的工作，诸如此类。结果是，我们经历了十年的破窗政策，却从未审视过它是否有效。今天你可以看到，对此有很多不满。你知道，人们很生气。对我来说，问题是，为什么政府不以受控和安全的方式提供其拥有的数据用于研究，这样就不会有隐私问题，但以一种允许公众辩论和科学评估政府及其政策是否有效的方式？
So I think that the sort of core thing is the government's very happy. to not have people know whether the government is working or not. They're not so much into this transparency and accountability thing. So they just don't really put much effort into releasing the data. Have you tried asking for some of this data? I mean, how would you unlock it from the government? Do you have to do a Freedom of Information Act request, or there are other avenues that you could use?
所以我认为核心问题是政府非常乐意不让人们知道政府是否在运作。他们对这种透明度和问责制不太感兴趣。所以他们真的没有投入太多精力来发布数据。你尝试过索要这些数据吗？我的意思是，你如何从政府那里解锁它？你必须提出《信息自由法》请求，还是有其他途径可以使用？
No, the thing that happens, and this happens in health also, is they make a defense that's based on, privacy. Right. Okay. But that's ridiculous. You know, those same people that say, oh, I can't share this with you because of privacy, take that same data and they give it to commercial subcontractors to optimize their
不，发生的事情，这在健康领域也发生过，是他们以隐私为由进行辩护。对。好吧。但这很荒谬。你知道，那些说“哦，因为隐私我不能和你分享这个”的同一群人，却拿着同样的数据给商业分包商来优化他们的
processes, to make more money to whatever they do. And it works just fine in the sense that you don't get data breaches, you don't get violations of privacy. You take the data, you strip out the identifiers, you give it to somebody for a particular purpose under a contract that makes them liable for screwing up, unlike, say, Equifax or somebody. Right? So make them liable so they're on the hook, and then you monitor them. Works fine.
流程，为了赚更多的钱，无论他们做什么。而且它运行得很好，因为你不会遇到数据泄露，你不会遇到侵犯隐私的情况。你获取数据，剥离标识符，在合同下将其交给某人用于特定目的，合同使他们对搞砸负责，不像Equifax或其他什么人。对吧？所以让他们负责，这样他们就承担责任，然后你监控他们。运行得很好。
Why don't we do that so that we can check on the government? Yeah? It would be sort of interesting to know whether some of these policies are really working or not. Recently there was some very brave people within the IRS that made data available to researchers like that. And it's remarkable, 30 years of data from the IRS about the outcomes of different minorities across the entire country and what conditions lead to intergenerational mobility. And that data just absolutely puts the nail in a lot of theories from both the left and the right. And it's interesting because, you know, they've had that data for generations.
为什么我们不这样做，以便我们可以监督政府？是吗？知道其中一些政策是否真的有效会很有趣。最近，国税局内有一些非常勇敢的人向研究人员提供了这样的数据。这非常了不起，来自国税局的30年数据，关于全国各地不同少数群体的结果，以及什么条件导致代际流动。这些数据绝对终结了左派和右派的许多理论。这很有趣，因为，你知道，他们几代人以来一直拥有这些数据。
So you stand back and you say, okay, so they have this data that could have, you know, kept millions, literally millions, maybe tens of millions of lives from jail, other sorts of suffering. And they didn't let anybody look at it. Doesn't that seem wrong? I think it's very wrong. So what this is is sort of, what I'm saying is we need to bring science to the data that we already have.
所以你退后一步说，好吧，所以他们拥有这些数据，本可以，你知道，让数百万，确实是数百万，也许数千万人的生命免于入狱，免于其他形式的痛苦。而他们却不让任何人看。这难道不错误吗？我认为这非常错误。所以这就是，我所说的是我们需要将科学带入我们已经拥有的数据中。
We need to do it in a controlled way that preserves privacy and so forth, of course. But we need a lot more accountability and transparency using the data that already exists. And I think that people are spending too much, time yelling about, oh, you know, we're all Facebook is doing whatever and ignoring the big thing, which is the government's not letting us figure out what's actually going on. So what are you working on now? What's next for you in this arena?
我们当然需要以一种保护隐私等受控的方式来做。但我们需要利用现有的数据进行更多的问责和透明度。我认为人们花太多时间大喊大叫，“哦，你知道，我们都在脸书上做任何事情”，而忽略了大事，那就是政府不让我们弄清楚到底发生了什么。那么你现在在做什么？在这个领域你接下来要做什么？
Well, I run a group that does a couple things. We do, actually we build software and things to help do this sort of release of data. Interestingly, So we're funded by like the government of France, not the government of the United States. That's a little interesting. They build in systems to let them have better accountability for their data. And then we do analytics. And the typical thing that we're focused on is what are the conditions that help communities grow and become more innovative and more successful? And those are things, it turns out, some of the biggest effects are, not surprisingly, diversity, access and integration with the rest of the community.
嗯，我管理一个做几件事的团队。我们实际上构建软件和工具来帮助进行这种数据发布。有趣的是，我们是由法国政府资助的，而不是美国政府。这有点意思。他们构建系统以让他们更好地对其数据负责。然后我们进行分析。我们关注的典型问题是，什么条件有助于社区成长并变得更具创新性和成功？事实证明，其中一些最大的影响因素，不出所料，是多样性、获取机会以及与社区其他部分的融合。
One of the biggest things that's happened in this country, but also in Europe and elsewhere, is a mass segregation based on income. Now, there's racial segregation, too. I'm not saying there isn't. But the new thing on the block is by income. by SES. So the poor folks live over there and the rich. And our data show that they do not mix at all, except maybe in Walmart. Seriously, Walmart places like that are one of the few places where rich people and poor people actually rub shoulders occasionally. The consequence, of course, is that they don't talk to each other, they don't understand each other,
在这个国家，以及在欧洲和其他地方，发生的最大事情之一是基于收入的大规模隔离。现在，也有种族隔离。我不是说没有。但新出现的问题是按收入划分。按社会经济地位（SES）。所以穷人住在那里，富人住在那里。我们的数据显示，他们根本不混合，除了可能在沃尔玛。说真的，沃尔玛之类的地方是富人和穷人偶尔真正肩并肩的少数地方之一。当然，结果是他们不互相交谈，他们不了解彼此，
and a lot of the things we do can be very hurtful to poor people because there's no understanding of the context of what's happening. So those are the sorts of things we do. Again, it's interesting who funds that. So it's people like European governments and some of the big financial firms are interested in that sort of thing. What's different about the European governments that they're interested in this and ours is not?
我们所做的许多事情可能对穷人非常有害，因为没有对正在发生的事情的背景的理解。所以这些就是我们所做的事情。同样，谁资助这些研究很有趣。所以是像欧洲政府和一些大型金融公司这样的人对这类事情感兴趣。欧洲政府对这一点感兴趣而我们政府不感兴趣，有什么不同？
Well, the thing that's really different in Europe is that they've taken steps to enforce privacy law. And this is something that I was integral to at the very beginning. I ran the discussion in Davos, or co-led the discussion in Davos that led to creation of the privacy laws there. So they're wrestling with the fact that a lot of business as usual has to stop. it has to change. And they have to understand how it is that you can be more respectful about people's control of their own data and still have a working society. And the hope is that by sort of getting ahead of this curve having to do with privacy and so
嗯，欧洲真正不同的是，他们已经采取措施执行隐私法。这是我在最开始就参与其中的事情。我在达沃斯主持了讨论，或者共同主持了达沃斯导致那里隐私法创建的讨论。所以他们正在努力应对这样一个事实，即许多照常营业的做法必须停止。它必须改变。他们必须了解如何才能更尊重人们对自己数据的控制，同时仍然拥有一个正常运作的社会。希望通过在隐私方面走在曲线前面，
forth that they can set the standard for the world and, you know, their companies will do well. And that, you know, their hope is that companies like Facebook, will retreat because of their poor handling of private data. And some of their companies in Europe will advance because they're more friendly to people's actual interests. This is a little out of left field, but I think I read that some years back you were involved in the development of Google Glass.
他们可以为世界设定标准，你知道，他们的公司会做得很好。而且，你知道，他们的希望是像脸书这样的公司会因为对私人数据处理不当而退缩。而欧洲的一些公司会因为对人们的实际利益更友好而前进。这有点离题，但我记得几年前你参与了谷歌眼镜的开发。
Yeah. And I just wanted to ask you a little bit about that because it kind of came and went. Everybody thought it was going to be the new, new thing. and it didn't work out too well. Why not? Well, some almost 25 years ago now, we really broke into the area of wearable computing
是的。我只是想问你一点关于那个的问题，因为它来去匆匆。每个人都认为它会是新的、新的东西。但它并没有太成功。为什么不呢？嗯，现在大约25年前，我们真正进入了可穿戴计算领域
and tried to build our own Google Glass and stuff. And one of my students, Thad Starner, who's now at Georgia Tech, went on from that experience and actually was one of the technical leads for Google Glass. It wasn't me, I'd like to call myself the Godfather and not the father. I think what it was is it was early to market, and it was a good example of the geeks thinking that everybody was a geek.
并试图构建我们自己的谷歌眼镜之类的东西。我的一个学生萨德·斯塔纳（Thad Starner），现在在佐治亚理工学院，从那次经历中继续前进，实际上是谷歌眼镜的技术负责人之一。不是我，我喜欢称自己为教父，而不是父亲。我认为它是过早进入市场，这是一个极客认为每个人都是极客的好例子。
It's a good idea. It's really cool for, you know, like surgeons and people building things where you need to see the plans while your hands are busy. Right, right. The thing that they did that was probably the biggest mistake is stick a camera in it at the beginning before people were used to it. and it might have been very successful. People will keep trying it. Eventually, we're going to have little displays in our glasses. Yeah, it's coming.
这是一个好主意。它真的很酷，你知道，比如外科医生和建造东西的人，当你手忙脚乱时需要看计划。对，对。他们所做的可能是最大的错误，就是在人们习惯它之前，在它里面装了一个摄像头。它可能非常成功。人们会继续尝试它。最终，我们的眼镜里会有小显示屏。是的，它要来了。
And it'll be good because it's going to result in not forgetting people's names, not getting lost. All of us somewhat older people are going to have better memories than we might otherwise had, etc. Sounds great. Well, thank you, Dr. Pentland. Thank you for joining us today. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts such as APA journals dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes, which discusses the practice of psychology. You can find all APA podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts.
而且它会很好，因为它会导致不会忘记人们的名字，不会迷路。我们所有稍微年长的人都会有比原本更好的记忆力，等等。听起来不错。好吧，谢谢你，彭特兰博士。感谢您今天加入我们。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他很棒的播客，例如《美国心理学会期刊对话》，讨论最新和最令人兴奋的心理学研究；以及《进度记录》，讨论心理学实践。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到所有美国心理学会的播客。
You can also go to our website, Speakingof Psychology.org, to listen to more episodes and see more resources on the topics we discuss. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association, and this is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你也可以访问我们的网站 SpeakingofPsychology.org，收听更多剧集并查看关于我们讨论主题的更多资源。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯，这是《心理学谈话》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。